in 1978 Dianne Feinstein then president
of the San Francisco Board of
Supervisors made this shocking
announcement
supervisor Harvey Milk
have been shot and killed
this moment would thrust her into the
national Spotlight part of a five
decade-long career in politics serving
as the first female mayor of San
Francisco thank you before running for
the U.S Senate in 1992 people are
hurting they're looking for change it's
really the first time in my political
life that I have found that being a
woman isn't a disadvantage Feinstein's
first major piece of legislation was the
assault weapons ban which was passed in
1994. I became mayor as a product of
assassination I'm aware I found my
assassinated colleague and put a finger
through a bull hole Bullet Hole trying
to get I proposed gun control
legislation in San Francisco Senator I
know something about what Firearms can
do gun control would remain a priority
throughout her career you have to say
enough is enough you have to say that
there is no reason to make
a semi-automatic assault weapon into a
fully automatic Battlefield weapon
Feinstein was not only the first woman
to represent California in the Senate
she was also the first to chair the
Senate select committee on intelligence
producing a landmark report on the cia's
interrogation of terrorist suspects
after the 9 11 attacks even if one were
to set aside all of the moral arguments
our review was a meticulous and detailed
examination of Records
it finds that coercive interrogation
techniques did not produce the vital
otherwise unavailable intelligence the
CIA has claimed and she was the first
woman to serve on the powerful Judiciary
Committee it would be very difficult for
me to vote to confirm someone to the
Supreme Court whom I knew would overturn
Roe Feinstein faced questions in her
final years about whether she was still
up to serving in the Senate and
announced in 2023 that she would not run
for re-election after her death at the
age of 90 on September 29th colleagues
from both parties paid tribute fan made
her Mark and everything from National
Security to the environment gun safety
to protecting civil liberties
she was
an incredibly effective
person at every line at every level and
she was at all of those levels on the
way to the Senate when Diane spoke the
rest of us stopped and we listened today
there are 25 women serving in this
chamber and every one of them would
admit
they stand on Diane's shoulders
foreign